parte 2 ve la región ese es la base de
un sólido cuyos cortes transversales
perpendiculares al eje x son cuadrados
encuentra el volumen del sólido muy bien
entonces la región s está aquí y en la
parte a habíamos dicho que esta era la
función f y que esta era la función g
ahora puedes poner valores en las
funciones para ver cómo se comportan
pero observa a la función g tiene este
término x elevado a la cuarta lo cual
hace que la función g tenga esta forma
mientras que la función f aunque tenga a
este término x tiene este término
exponencial lo cual dada la función f la
tendencia de ir hacia arriba mientras x
va creciendo puedes ver que la función
también crece porque está exponencial la
hará positiva entonces bueno veamos las
regiones estas las regiones y pensemos
en varias cosas como cuáles son las
cotas de las regiones
vemos que las cotas superior de las
regiones es x 2 pero este valor este
valor de aquí no lo conocemos así que
bueno ya vemos lea como no lo conocemos
le pondré un signo de interrogación no
conocemos ese valor de x pero sí sabemos
que en este valor las funciones son
iguales es decir sabemos que fedea es
igual a g de a
ahora en la sección anterior en la
sección a hablamos del valor absoluto de
fx
x lo cual calculamos y se guarda una
calculadora también podríamos decir que
el valor absoluto de efe - g de a es
igual a cero
ahora aquí no se necesita el valor
absoluto porque bueno el valor absoluto
de 0 0 pero bueno esto ya lo habíamos
calculado entonces lo que pusimos en la
calculadora veamos cuando es igual a 0
en la calculadora ya habíamos calculado
el valor absoluto de fx de x entonces
podemos ver cuando eso es igual a cero
podemos ver que sólo hay tres casos
cuando eso ocurre el valor absoluto de
la diferencia de las funciones es igual
a cero
en este caso éste y éste queremos
conocer esta equis que ahora nombramos a
en este caso así que hagamos es una
calculadora
vamos a la función matemática bueno
primero voy a limpiar después quito este
modo y voy a matemática
bajó a solucionar recuerda que su bono
era el valor absoluto de la diferencia
de las funciones f g entonces queremos
saber cuándo que es sub uno es igual a
cero podemos intentar adivinar a está
entre 0 y 2 entonces a puede ser igual a
1 quizás así que oprimo
voy a oprimir alfa y solucionar
y veamos que obtenemos obtenemos x igual
a 1.03 por lo tanto
es aproximadamente 1.03 entonces que
integrar tomamos no queremos el área de
s si en ese tomamos cortes transversales
vamos a obtener cuadrados entonces esto
será la base de un cuadrado con longitud
de valor absoluto de fx gfx esa es la
longitud de la base pero si queremos el
área de ese corte transversal voy a
dibujar aquí algunos cortes
transversales ahí está uno y acá está
otro corte transversal entonces el área
de cada uno de esos cortes transversales
perpendiculares al eje x la longitud de
la base elevada al cuadrado pero lo
vamos a multiplicar por las de equis y
lo que obtienes así es el volumen
entonces el volumen b es igual a la
integral
desde x igual a donde a es
aproximadamente 1.03 hasta x2 la
integral desde hasta 2 de esto porque
esto es la longitud de un lado del
cuadrado pero queremos elevarlo al
cuadrado porque eso nos dará el área de
ese corte transversal entonces tenemos
la integral desde a hasta 2 del valor
absoluto de fx menos gx ahora esto lo
elevó al cuadrado
también podría yo ponerlo entre
paréntesis pero como ya como ya use el
valor absoluto en la calculadora bueno
ya lo dejaré como valor absoluto
entonces esto te dará el área de cada
uno de los cortes transversales
perpendiculares al eje x y lo
multiplicamos por de equis y así
obtienes el volumen al hacer la suma
desde x igualada hasta x igualados y
bueno ya hicimos mucho del trabajo en la
calculadora así que voy a sacar la
calculadora muy bien entonces el valor
de a en este caso es x igual a 1.03
entonces cambio de modo vamos a
matemática y bajó a la función de
integral definida selecciono
y ahora
no voy a tomar a jesus uno sino ye sub 1
al cuadrado
me voy a variables variable y función
tengo uno nuevo al cuadrado
mi variable de integración es x lo
calculó desde x igualada pero recuerda
que la calculadora guardo el valor de a
como x igual a 1.03 la primera x es mi
variable de integración la segunda es mi
cota inferior de integración las cotas
superiores 2 y obtengo veamos que
obtengo
1.283 por lo tanto el volumen es
aproximadamente 1.2 83 unidades cúbicas